Pixar just released the next sneak peek at
Incredibles 2 and hidden in the new footage
are some cool details and easter eggs you
might have missed.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm delving into the new Incredibles
2 trailer for Pixar easter eggs, superhero
references and a possible villain we haven't
yet met.
If you're new here, I do lots of Pixar and
superhero movie videos, so subscribe to my
channel to get everything as soon as I post
it.
Plus, I've got a new Pixar giveaway for all
my subscribers later in this video!
"Superheroes are illegal."
"We wanna fight bad guys!"
"Ajubadibaja!"
"It defines who I am!"
"We're not saying you have... what?!"
If like Mr Incredible, you're wondering where
this line came from, well, it seems to be
a cool reference to Batman Begins.
"It's not who I am underneath, but what I
do ... that defines me."
I love that Pixar are obviously continuing
to have fun with superhero lore and putting
their own spin on lines from Christopher Nolan's
Batman trilogy.
Also in this scene is a regular, but less
well-known, Pixar easter egg which is a very
specific Chinese take-out container design.
This same style of food box has appeared four
times previously in Pixar movies.
The first time was in A Bug's Life where it
was called the "Chinese Cabinet of Metamorphosis"
by Manny who used it for his circus act.
"From the most mysterious regions of uncharted
Asia, I give you the Chinese Cabinet Of Metamorphosis!"
Other places it's appeared in Pixar movies
include in the Pizza Planet Truck in Toy Story
2, in Linguini's apartment in Ratatouille,
and, most recently, in Inside Out where, like
the Incredibles family, Riley and her family
also sat down for a dinner of Chinese takeout.
"Help me bring supers back into the sunlight."
"We need Elastigirl!"
"Bye sweetie!"
"I'll watch the kids, no problem."
OK, so here we get our first look at Winston
Deavor and his Devtech organisation and he's
making it clear he wants to hire Elastigirl
for his own missions.
Now, if we jump back a moment to this shot
at the Municiberg airport, there's Elastigirl
arriving on her motorbike, but look really
carefully and you'll notice there's another
figure standing next to Winston Deavor.
I wonder if that could be his sister Evelyn,
who you can gather from her name – Evelyn
Deavor – sounds like she's probably going
to have a villainous role in the movie.
We also get to see that Elastigirl's been
kitted out with a new slick outfit as well
as a motorbike and they both have an interesting
new logo, which looks like the letters E and
G of Elastigirl have been combined.
And notice that the waterfall that Elastigirl
drives out of is a call-back to Syndrome's
lava waterfall which also worked as a hidden
opening in the first Incredibles movie.
On the surface, the math joke seems it's probably
a jab at the US Common Core math standard
and the criticism it's come under from parents.
"That's not the way you're supposed to do
it Dad."
"They want us to do it this..."
"I don't know that way!
Why would they change math?!"
"Math is math!"
"It's OK Dad!"
However, given the book Dash holds up is called
"New Math for Life", this might actually also
be a reference to the "New Math" syllabus
which was introduced in the 1960s in the US
and some European countries as an attempt
to improve mathematical skills and interest
in science during the Cold War.
Additionally, this fits in with the [19]60s-esque
setting of the Incredibles movies.
We also get a glimpse of Jack-Jack literally
turning into a little monster again, as he
did when he defended himself against Syndrome
at the end of the first film.
"But I can't keep giving him cookies!"
"Wow!"
"No biting the Daddy!"
The trailer's cut together pretty quickly,
but it looks like Jack-Jack gets this specific
power when he's angry, and it seems here it's
because Mr Incredible won't give him any more
cookies.
It was great to see Edna Mode back and, judging
by the look of Mr Incredible, I think he'll
be turning to her for help after becoming
exhausted trying to look after Jack-Jack.
As she did for Elastigirl in the first movie,
I'm sure this time she'll be offering him
some of her signature brand of advice!
"What are you talking about?"
"Huh?"
"You are Elastigirl!"
"My god, pull yourself together!"
And I wonder if she'll also be designing him
or Jack-Jack a new costume?
But no capes, of course, dahling!
"Something classic, like Dyna Guy!"
"Oh, he had a great look!"
"The cape and the boots!"
"No capes!"
So, were there any other things you spotted
or enjoyed about the new Incredibles 2 trailer?
And do you have any predictions or theories
about what Winston Deavor and his sister will
be up to in the sequel?
On this video, I'm starting a Pixar giveaway
for an awesome Art of Coco hardback book for
all my subscribers.
So, get subscribing and commenting about the
trailer for a chance to win!
If you liked this, then do hit the thumbs-up
and share the video with your friends.
Your support is hugely appreciated and if
you want to get all my new Pixar and superhero
videos, then tap the bell and join the notification
squad!
Coming next will be my Black Panther videos
plus a very special Coco video.
Until then, you can check out more videos
you might like right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!